à faire de viol d'agression de
harcèlement quel que soit le sujet
souvent les médias s'en emparent et la
machine ne s'arrête plus cette enquête
préliminaire ouverte pour viol contre
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor acteur Richard
Berry visé par une plainte déposée par
sa fille aînée habitant a été placé en
garde à vue d'autant plus lorsque ses
affaires concernent des célébrités
pourtant en France il existe la
présomption d'innocence un principe
selon lequel on ne doit pas rendre
coupable un individu avant qu'il ne soit
jugé un film dans lequel Richard Berry
n'est capteur a été déprogrammé de
France 3 c'est ça la présomption
innocence d'affaires ont montré que
souvent la télévision la presse les
réseaux sociaux s'improvisent en
tribunal médiatique c'est une histoire
sort des nains c'est le cas dans la
terre Richard Berry accusé d'un 16 par
sa fille Coline en février 2021 elle a
porté plainte contre lui pour viol et
agressions sexuelles de Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor accusé de lui par l’écrivaine
Florence forcel puis par une vingtaine
d'autres femmes de viol je suis rentré
dans le bureau 5 minutes après j'avais
son sexe dans ma bouche
en examen en novembre dernier pour viol
lui aussi il a été placé en garde à vue
dimanche précisément à la suite d'une
pour viol c'est pour certaines de ces
histoires elles ont abouti à un non-lieu
la vie de ces personnalités a pourtant
basculé et elle se tiennent aujourd'hui
loin des caméras alors les stars accusés
sont-elles condamnés d'avance
alors la question est posée oui non oui
non alors il n'y a il y a deux noms
allez-y Ludivine ben je pense que
effectivement le tribunal médiatique est
implacable effectivement que ce soit au
niveau de des jurés et tout bien sûr que
les jurys peuvent avoir déjà une sorte
de partie prix mais je pense qu'il y a
des personnes des personnalités qui ont
déjà subi de très lourdes des
accusations qui s'en sont remises on a
parlé dans dans l'extrait de Richard
Berry notamment qui exactement va en
reparler mais en tout cas visiblement ça
n'a pas impacté l'acide de sa carrière
souvenez-vous des accusations portées
aussi à l'époque sur Patrick Bruel qui
finalement ont été levés et ben il a été
il a été comme blanchi il y a plein
d'autres stars à l'époque Michael
Jackson qui d'ailleurs même été passé
avait été jugé
largement
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
après ils sont quand même blanchi en
tout cas ils sont réhabilités des comme
Bertrand Cantat qui a pris aussi ont
payé ont payé entre guillemets moi
j'estime qu'on n'a jamais véritablement
payé quand on a tué quelqu'un mais là
c'est pas de la présence mais là il a
été condamné puis ensuite après il a
quand même rempli des salles donc ce que
je vous dis je veux dire par là c'est
qu'effectivement la presse peut porter
ça ça porte un très très lourd jugement
très lourd poids mais il y a des
personnes qui peuvent en sortir
effectivement réhabilité
évidemment que la présomption
d'innocence elle est bafouée en
permanence parce que dès que ce sont des
Nantes très connues ça sort maintenant
ce qui a de formidable qui a beaucoup
changé c'est que la parole s'est libérée
et que les femmes osent parler et qu'il
faut écouter les femmes et que
maintenant heureusement les structures
ont évolué qu'on respecte la parole de
la femme qu'on la croit d'abord c'est
essentiel de la croire de prendre les
plaintes de respecter tout ce qu'elle
dit et de la croire à chaque fois
j'insiste là-dessus parce que ce n'était
pas encore le cas donc tout ça est
important mais maintenant quand vous
voyez que la présomption d'innocence
elle est bafouée ils se sont tous ils se
font tous déchirés de toute façon sur
les réseaux sociaux ce qui est de toute
façon assez presque habituel dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça il y a rien à faire c'est comme
ça le tribunal médiatique est beaucoup
plus important que la réalité des faits
vous voyez quand on a beau réhabiliter
des gens regardez le cas qui a foutu un
bon coup à MiTo c'est quand même
l'histoire de Johnny Depp parce que
Johnny Depp quand même alors je voulais
un bémol parce que l'affaire Denise
c'est une affaire de diffamation et
qu'on était dans un cadre de divorce et
que c'était pas une accusation publique
les conséquences pour les femmes en
Amérique ont été pas très bonnes
puisqu'on parle de même tous les hommes
aussi et on a remis en question la
parole de amberd mais Pascal a menti
devant un jury c'est un peu différent
mais effectivement pour donner
ABSOLUMENT ce qu'il a il a gagné
Guillaume oui c'est évident qu'il y a un
tribunal médiatique
ça dépend des affaires ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il y a un tribunal médiatique
que c'est beaucoup aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux et Twitter qui font la
justice avant la justice et que ce qui
regrettable c'est que quand il y a des
dossiers qui sont classés sans suite
comme c'était le cas pour Richard Berry
il y a énormément d'articles quand les
affaires et les scandales sortent quand
les affaires sont classés sans suite
personne n'en parle pourquoi parce que
ces affaires elles font du clic mais
quand ils sont innocentés ou que c'est
classé sans suite personne n'en parle et
je pense qu'il y a un énorme préjudice
pour toutes les personnalités qui ont
été victimes de ça et ce préjudice il
doit être réparé ça a des impacts
dramatiques sur les carrières quand
c'est des acteurs des humoristes ou des
personnalités ne travaillent plus
pendant des mois et ça c'est vrai
sur le plateau TPMP on va avoir sur
témoignage
l'idée qui est en deux secondes d'abord
ferme la porte à clé alors que personne
ne ferme la clé la porte à clé puis et
puis en moins de temps qu'il faut pour
le dire il est en caleçon voilà et donc
je suis stupéfaite par ce geste
totalement
disproportionné des placés
pathétique je lui dis mais tu connais
mes liens tu connais mes relations tu
sais très bien que enfin je développe
pas autant que tu connais mes liens avec
la présidence et ça l'a stoppé net alors
pour vous Jean-Pascal c'est non on n'est
pas qu'on allait d'avance non parce que
la finalité des choses c'est la justice
qui doit rendre un jugement et c'est pas
parce que moi ce qui ce qui m'emmerde un
petit peu c'est que on parle justement
de ces de ces Instagram de ces Twitter
où les gens font le jugement avant même
qui soit arrivé et on invite alors je
dis pas qu'il faut pas les inviter c'est
normal on est dans un plateau il faut
parler des sujets graves d'actualité
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on prépare le
jugement on prépare le procès avant même
qu'il arrive et c'est ça qui m'embête
parce que alors oui il y a des plaintes
etc pour l'instant ces personnes sont
innocentes et j'ai l'impression qu'on se
on veut nous faire d'abord le procès et
on verra après la suite je pense qu'il
faudrait peut-être justement peut-être
calmer ça attendre les résultats et
peut-être après inviter les gens
justement parce que la finalité de tout
ça c'est la justice doit rendre un
jugement et tant que c'est paru on n'a
pas on peut se faire une idée mais j'ai
l'impression le problème c'est que quand
le jugement sera passé peut-être qu'on
dira il est on ne sait pas donc je veux
dire on donne un résultat avant même
qu'on a fait quoi que ce soit donc c'est
ça qui m'embête un petit peu
c'est la question qu'on te pose donc
c'est oui effectivement il a pas compris
la justice elle a deux vitesses c'est à
dire que tu as la justice des réseaux
sociaux et comment judiciaire la justice
judiciaire tu en as pour deux trois ans
de prouver tu as ton innocence ou ta
culpabilité ou la culpabilité de l'autre
mais en attendant
derrière elle est foutue alors je suis
pas sûr moi je suis les victimes de PPDA
c'est autre chose parce que je trouve
que c'est pas des femmes qui sont partis
faire des tweets au contraire il y a eu
des enquêtes il a fallu les faire parler
les aider à parler etc donc c'est pas le
même combat je trouve que PDF c'est un
autre dossier mais il y a des dossiers
aujourd'hui sur le web aujourd'hui alors
on se parle il est toujours résumé
innocent ok mais quand bien même
il est pas là que mes faim
j'ai compris mais en fait il y a quand
même un dossier qui est quand même comme
disait Guillaume pardon il est il est
c'est un dossier qui est lourd avec
beaucoup de témoignages énormément de
témoignages mais sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui vous pouvez tuer quelqu'un
en inventant un truc en racontant
n'importe quoi en mettant une meute on
appelle ça le harcèlement en meute où
vous avez des milliers de personnes qui
vont vous abuser quelque chose voilà
c'est un raid numérique des milliers de
personnes qui vont vous accuser de
quelque chose qui sont fausses parce que
judiciairement c'est faux et vous faites
quoi
j'essaie de quoi je parle la réalité des
faits c'est que vous ne faites rien tu
n'as que ton regard ton miroir et tu
pleures et tu attends que la justice se
décide à te recevoir à t'écouter tu en
as pour 3 ans mais ça c'est un débat
c'est le retard c'est le retard
il y a 30 secondes Richard Berry c'était
c'était assez lourd les témoignages
contre lui c'est voilà ça partait très
mal et aujourd'hui il est blanchi on a
reçu son ex-femme ceux qui me sur le
plateau qui a expliqué que tout ça a été
pour elle et donc aujourd'hui on est
d'accord que c'est classé sans suite et
il remonte sur scène mais tant mieux
aujourd'hui il y a plus de conséquences
non et c'est un des rares pour lequel il
y a eu peu de conséquences a priori mais
c'est vrai que le rôle des médias il est
compliqué parce qu'à la fois on se dit
que c'est pas forcément leur rôle de
médiatiser des plaintes qui sont encore
au stade de plainte et pour lesquelles
il va y avoir a priori un jugement une
enquête donc c'est pas drôle les et d'un
autre côté quand on voit PPDA c'est
aussi le rôle de porter la voix de ceux
ou celles qui ne se font pas entendre en
fait qu'est-ce qui se passe avec PPDA
c'est qu'il y a un témoignages il se
passe rien de témoignages il se passe
rien et à chaque fois une sorte de
réponse qui est faite à travers le canal
médiatique parce qu'il ne se passe rien
et PPDA c'est toujours plus de
témoignages et en face rien et lui qui
entre guillemets le culot de venir sur
un plateau télé dire tout ça c'est faux
et ces femmes menthe parce qu'elle
témoignent de manière anonyme donc là
ils ont témoigné à visage découvert et
ensuite les médias sont là permettent
aussi de porter les voix de celles qui
ne se sont pas entendre même par la
justice dans l'affaire Berry commune
Serreau colonie pardon à fait appel donc
ça peut ça peut encore changer alors
autre cas qui est assez différent c'est
Jean-Jacques Bourdin il a été récemment
licencié le groupe Altice il y a une
négociation c'est vrai que ça ressemble
quand même à voilà un accord entre les
deux parties puisque il y avait un
prudent possible et que ça pouvait
pencher d'un côté comme de l'autre mais
dans le cadeau Jacques Bourdin il a été
totalement blanchi mais c'est un
classement sans suite ça veut dire que
l'effet qu'on lui reproche non pas
existé comme vous faites dans ce cas là
donc dans ce cas précis ah ben de toute
façon il a il a négocié son départ était
bien obligé il voulait le virer de toute
façon depuis longtemps à l'arrivée ce
monsieur qu'on aime pas il a été
l'essentiel de son il a perdu son emploi
suite à une accusation avec un joli
chèque je veux dire il part il
travaillera plus là on se dit des fois
leur carrière sont foutues lui il était
plus en fin de carrière il a pris son
chèque il va rester chez lui c'est
exactement l'exemple regardez quand je
vous disais par exemple Johnny Depp
alors oui c'est une autre affaire mais
regardez son image était très entachée
il ne faisait plus Pirates des Caraïbes
parce qu'il était ingérable etc
aujourd'hui il revient ils vont leur
refaire signer donc quelque chose
doit réembaucher Jean-Jacques Bourdin
aujourd'hui mais oui pourquoi pas alors
moi perso je n'aime pas du tout Jean de
Bourdin je dis personnellement je
déteste en tant que
j'ai répondu
jamais voilà donc ça veut dire que la
conséquence cette semaine voilà TF1 a
dit non il y a qu'aujourd'hui suite à
cette affaire classé sans suite mais où
il y a quand même des témoignages et
plusieurs témoignages y compris dans
l'hôtel où ça s'est passé mais tout ça
pour l'instant est resté sans suite
parce qu'il y a pas d'accusation les
frais sont prescrits mais n'oublions pas
qu'ils l'enquête quand même interne qui
a été faite laisse et voilà nous laisse
supposer qu'il y a eu beaucoup de de
choses qui ne devaient pas se passer
là-bas puisque on a même si elles ne
sont pas préjudiciables et compte que
judiciairement on peut pas l'attaquer il
a eu des comportements inappropriés et
ça aussi ça a été révélé il y a un autre
cas qu'on va aborder parce que là pour
le coup c'est typiquement là c'est une
affaire de justice c'est arrêtant il se
passe ce qui se passe on en a déjà parlé
pour lui tout allait bien il a un
témoignage d'une femme avec qui il avait
déjà eu des relations consenties
il y a une enquête là pour le coup une
instruction et aujourd'hui arihabitant
je vous le dis a perdu l'ensemble de son
contrat et il n'est pas prêt de tourner
un mètre de péloche et de ranger sur et
pour à mon avis plusieurs années mais
imaginez que suite à l'enquête ce soit
pour le coup blanchit qui dit que ça
repartira pas peut-être après si les
voitures non mais non mais
on sait pas moi je vous dis moi je vous
dis c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est
extrêmement compliqué alors au-delà ça
quand même libéré la parole et il y a
des femmes aujourd'hui qui peuvent
s'exprimer et ça permet de vraiment il y
a des victimes qui se sentent plus à
l'aise d'en parler sur les réseaux etc
et ça permet de déceler plein de choses
donc ça c'est important de le dire mais
il y a aussi un mélange de fausses
histoires qui s'y mettent et ça a les
mêmes conséquences aussi dramatiques
croyez moi pour bah du coup ces gens qui
sont victimes de lynchage
imaginez la même histoire pour un
rébitant sans les réseaux j'aurais pu
avoir une instruction qui serait restée
peut-être
discrète et il y aurait continué à
bosser et on aurait su après s'il y
avait ou pas une condamnation là il
était condamné par avance après encore
une fois en question
quand elle a porté plainte elle a été
poussée par la police à le faire elle ne
s'est jamais voulait pas le faire parce
qu'ils avaient une relation depuis
longtemps plutôt amoureuse bon ils
avaient des rapports assez violents
visiblement il a été apparemment j'ai
aimé ça c'est au conditionnel
trop trop trop trop violent puisqu'il y
a un médecin l'a constaté donc voilà
maintenant elle voulait pas porter
plainte du tout ce sont les la police
c'est la police qui a insisté et alors
qu'à inverse avait aussi c'est Jean-Luc
Lahaye ouais alors vous avez enquêté sur
accusé de viol sur mineur d'environ 15
ans c'est une affaire vraiment sordide
parce que c'est des jeunes femmes très
jeunes qui étaient fan du chanteur il
aura encore une fois joué de sa
notoriété pour les approcher pour les
emmener et les approcher de lui via les
réseaux sociaux via facebook c'est
d'ailleurs Facebook qui aurait détecté
des conversations suspectes via un outil
automatique entre Jean-Luc Lahaye et
c'est jeune fille et ce qui est encore
plus sordide c'est que les maires de ces
jeunes filles seraient complices et
aurait même filmé les rapports sexuels
entre leurs filles et Jean-Luc Lahay
c'était fan les mamans étaient fans il
est passé lui par la case prison mais
sur le coup d'un sursis donc une
deuxième plainte et donc il est bien
prison il a été libéré depuis
aujourd'hui sa carrière elle est
évidemment totalement arrêtée c'est
terminé terminé et lui il dit que ces
jeunes femmes mentent et qu'elles
étaient consentantes
attention avec une mineure de 15 ans
bah ouais en fait il y a un moment donné
il y a une condamnation là ça on n'est
pas dans la présentation d'innocence on
est dans une fin alors pour l'instant le
paradoxe si justement c'est que le
paradis aujourd'hui il est présumé il ne
sort même si de fortes présomption il
est pour l'instant pas condamné à la
reconnu qu'il avait eu des rapports avec
lui
le paradoxe va plus loin c'est que
concernant Jean-Luc Lahaye pardon et
c'est comme beaucoup de personnalités
voilà dont on connaît généralement un
petit peu les casseroles ça fait des
années qui a de d'énormes rumeurs
concernant Jean-Luc Lahaye et voilà et
ses préférences pour les jeunes filles
et pour faire des choses pas très
catholiques et donc là ça le rattrape
aujourd'hui mais ça fait des années que
dans la dans le système on connaît un
petit peu voilà sa façon de faire quoi
et ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
l'idée de timing c'est à dire pourquoi
c'est scandale sorte à ce moment-là
Jean-Jacques Bourdin l'affaire sera en
plein élection présidentielle c'est un
peu son grand retour à la télé puisqu'il
anime des prime sur BF avec des
personnalités politiques je crois pas la
Kabbale moi on sait claire sur le timing
c'est des affaires comme le dit Ludivine
tout le monde on entend parler depuis
des années regardez DSK pareil c'était
l'homme politique préféré des Français
ça sort comme par hasard juste avant
l'élection présidentielle c'est comme
des animaux
ou quelques semaines après les fesses
supposer sa sœur la constat circule
depuis des années et que ça sort un
moment précis il y a peut-être aussi de
volonté de déstabiliser de déstabiliser
ces personnalités et une forme
d'hypocrisie puisque tout le monde le
sait depuis des années on est d'accord